foreign
where are you from originally where'd
you grow up Southwest suburb of Chicago
um called Warrenville
and tell me about your family growing up
you had Mom and Dad yeah uh mom and dad
they're actually still together to this
day surprisingly
um
how would you describe yourself
uh my childhood
was uh it was a little rough in the
aspect of
um
capital punishment was used a lot in my
house I come from a martial arts
background so if we're getting scolded
uh it was like this yes sir no sir
if I'm dropping my guard a little bit
I'm getting cracked upside the head
um
but uh at nine years old for example I
actually had to take courses on how to
take care of an infant because that's
when my little brother was born and I
would have to stay home from I thought
it was cool because I didn't have to go
to school but I had to watch my little
brother and take care of him because
both my parents had to work double
shifts to keep the roof over our head so
we didn't have a lot of money
um and I was the babysitter
um essentially
um but uh which is pretty stressful for
a nine-year-old to have an infant's Life
In His Hands uh but I think I did a good
job you know my little brother today is
like my best friend
um but uh you know dad was a drinker
um
come from the British I'm half Sicilian
half British uh we never talked to the
Sicilian side of the family ever and I
don't know why
um but just to kind of give you a an
idea I got a detention once in third
grade and I ran away from home because I
was scared what what my dad was going to
do to me about the detention
uh by the time I was 10 years old they
put locks on the Wicker cabinets because
me and my younger brother were drinking
all their alcohol
um so I actually started drinking at
about eight years old
um
and you know I I remember the first time
I my parents you know I come from a rock
and roll background you know he was in a
band They toured all over the country
and they rode motorcycles
and I remember hiding under the table as
a kid
grabbing my dad's uh gin slamming it
and hearing his friend say Stanley I
think your son just drank your drink and
he said well I guess he's going to be
[ __ ] up then
and I was and um at the time he was left
haha look at the little kid he's drunk
but then once everyone leaves now I'm
getting my ass beat because I'm I'm an
embarrassment to the family so it was it
was a lot of that back and forth stuff
not knowing when I'm gonna get beat up
for what
um so there was physical abuse there
there was mental abuse there
um I was pretty lucky on the sexual
abuse I I escaped two different
pedophiles from the neighborhood
um so I I got pretty lucky as a child
with the the pedophilia stuff but uh it
was it was physical violence so on a
daily basis I mean he put my mom in the
hospital before
um I have years of my wife that are
blacked out my brain won't let me
remember
um I think it's like a defense type
thing that your brain does for you to
keep you sane
um where my other brother remembers
things and I thought he was lying but
he's not stuff did happen
um as far as the the violence goes
um but besides that
uh growing up in the suburb of Chicago
in the 80s
we play Ghost in the graveyard you know
we we would uh a lot of outside Outdoors
um not like the kids today with all the
video games like we went outside and
played
uh I was me and my brother were the Bad
Kids on the Block so that was a little
rough sometimes because the uh other the
neighbor kids parents wouldn't let their
kids play with us
um so we're alone a lot
but
I did get a lot of freedom uh I could
basically do and go wherever I wanted
which is not necessarily a good thing
for a kid always but I could do that
um I'd like to say that
um
my childhood
it's
I'd like to say it was a good childhood
um but after having lots of therapy over
the years I am an adult abused child the
way that I was raised uh my mom used to
put my thumb in Tabasco sauce because I
sucked my thumb till I was about eight
and I just heard about a woman going to
jail for doing that to her kid recently
it's considered child abuse today
I just love spicy food now
um do you finish High School I did uh
yep I got my high school diploma I
graduated third in my class
from the bottom
um the only two that were lower than me
were mentally challenged
uh that was my goal pretty much though
was to smoke as much weed as possible
and sleep as much as I possibly could
and still get that diploma and I did it
I admission complete on the high school
um I was very proud of being a slacker I
think they were just kind of tired of
seeing me there so they got me out of
that's cool
um what'd you do after high school
After High School well
um okay well at about 16 years old so I
would have still been in high school
um there is an organization called the
Latin Kings um their gang
and they would Advance me
um large quantities of marijuana to sell
um and
so for a 16 year old I had more money
than all my other friends
[Music]
um
they call me barbecue because if I was
scared the phones might be tapped so if
I say I'm barbecuing that means I got
weed so that's how that nickname stuck
um
but uh I dropped out of a couple
different colleges
and I just pretty much sold a lot of
weed
then I met some people that were in
Telecom sales
and I worked as a sales manager for ATT
on and off for about 17 years which I
thought was an accomplishment with no
credentials uh and criminal background
but I would actually sell business
accounts uh on and off the addiction
kind of controlled how often I would be
working
um at the time the drug uh well
okay and I'm sorry if I talk faster jump
around trying not to but uh I drink
alcohol from the age of 8 to 21.
um I started doing heroin at 21 years
old
and uh that I instantly fell in love
with it
um
I quit drinking all to the together
completely and devoted it to heroin at
that time
um I've never stole anything in my life
until I got addicted to heroin
and uh it was from my own parents too
and I told on myself
um but back then they didn't know what
to do so they threw me in the psychord
uh and that was the beginning of
my life getting very very hard after
that
um I I got kicked out of my folks house
and I'll never forget the first time
being homeless in Illinois I mean we get
Negative 30 wind chills up there
sometimes it's cold
um I woke up in a park bench and I was
shivering
and there was Frost all over the grass
and that was the first time that I
really contemplated suicide
um
very depressing
and I felt really betrayed by my own
Folks at that point but uh
to answer your question I'm trying not
to ramble too much so you can ask me
questions no it's okay you're doing good
and so you you've been living on the
streets for how long
I've been chronically homeless for 20
years now
um but you've had jobs during some of
that time I've had pretty much the same
job okay which is also an interesting
thing ATT
not corporate obviously
um my boss is more or less an Italian
mobster
and he was able to ghost me into his
company as a subcontractor
uh regardless of the fact that I have
felony possession drug charges
regardless of the fact that I don't have
any sort of sales or business
credentials but despite having a job the
the drug addiction keeps you homeless
um event yeah it would go to that
eventually
um in the beginning it would actually
seem to enhance my ability to work but
then it's either I'm too strung out I'm
either too high to work or I'm too sick
to work eventually and uh
I grew up with a lot of gangs
surrounding me
but I did not want to be a gang banger I
never joined a gang uh so and I don't
like to steal either so when I didn't
have a job it's panhandling is how I
would support my habit
um I have done things though other
things for money
uh I had prostituted myself before
um not proud of that at all but I can
talk about it pretty easy now
um
uh basically everything that I never
thought I would ever do I have done
uh I never thought I'd use a needle
uh after about a year of using heroin I
used a needle for the first time
um and the addiction only progresses
then
so when you you've been in La how long
uh okay so L.A I've been here this is
day number 18 for me
and I left Chicago
okay this is this is real [ __ ] up here
what I'm about to tell you
um I left Chicago one of the reasons I
love show I was just one of them
there's a a guy there who he did 19
years for murder
and
um his job in prison was to rape for the
Gangster Disciple organization
and
um he fancied me quite a bit
I'm not gay number one
and I'm actually kind of scared of the
guy
well because I denied him a romantic
relationship with me
he decided that I needed to die
so I would constantly have to worry
about this guy trying to kill me
um jail was something he's not afraid of
he's at home there
um so that was one of the reasons I was
wanting to get away from having to
constantly worry about this person
on top of the violence is just uh I mean
the poverty is over 500 000 now in
Chicago so it's
very you got a lot of people doing a lot
of really desperate things and when it
gets cold it only gets worse
um and being homeless for that many
years
um
I don't
a lot of the uh the cptsd the complex
post-traumatic stress syndrome that I
have is from being uh homeless in the
cold
um because it's it's quite hard to
survive sometimes when it's that cold
you you just have to kind of figure out
where you can go and if you can't go
anywhere you might freeze to death
um it's a very very stressful
environment
so I left Chicago I came here
um on the way here
I took an Amtrak train
um of course I had a very bad uh
opiate habit
I've already developed there well I made
it all the way to New Mexico and they
decided that I was too sick to be on the
train
um they called the police
I accidentally sent myself into
precipitated withdrawal on the train
and I was escorted off the train so I
was stuck there for about three days
uh but I got to LA
and I and then I got the Skid Row
and
um it didn't shock me at all uh I uh
actually felt like this feels a little
bit kind of like home to me
um
and uh
so two things happened
in La here the second day I was here
there's a gang here called the um
they're called gbg they're the gay boy
gangsters is what they're called
I guess they're out of West Hollywood
but it started in prison
um well this particular incident I I was
just by myself on the outskirts of
downtown
somebody asked me if hey you want to
smoke
sure why not you know because people
here are a lot friendlier than Chicago
they say hi
um they talk to you uh Chicago we have a
three second rule we don't look at each
other
so okay cool maybe I made a new friend
so we go to this there's like this
bridge
which I was already looking thinking
going down there anyway I jumped down
there but then there's this cave
basically in the side of the cliff
and there's already two people in there
well we go in there
and uh
I didn't see it coming at all but um
the two there's so there's three of them
and one of me
and they were kind of they decided they
all wanted to have sex with each other
and I didn't think that was happening
because I I just don't think about I'm
not gay so I wasn't thinking about men
having sex so I'm just kind of sitting
there and it was their laying side by
side like this
and I was sitting on this end like this
and when I look over at them I can see
what's going on and obviously I felt
very uncomfortable
um thank God the which I found out later
was like the boss he stopped he kind of
stopped he said maybe we should get
friendly at a different time
and uh
one of the other ones replied don't
worry don't worry man we're not gonna
[ __ ] you like that
so in in an instant they decided they
were going to be friends with me and not
rape me
so a couple weeks go by uh it's been
it's been three days now since this
other thing happened
um
uh I don't remember exactly where I was
uh I was trying to go somewhere
different to panhandle
um
I still have to support this uh
addiction that I have
I do have liver cancer now so I'm in a
lot of pain
and
um I use the fentanyl medicinally if you
can wrap your mind around that I
actually think it's keeping me alive at
this point
but anyway
I went to a different part of La that
was I was unfamiliar with trying to find
somewhere new to go
and
it's it gets blurry
um
someone invited me to come smoke some
marijuana with them
and there's a couple other people there
I was drugged I don't know what type of
drug it was because I've never felt that
way before
I was in and out of consciousness
um
very confused and disoriented
but I was held prisoner for about three
and a half days and I was raped
um
I don't know how many times I was raped
or or by how many people I don't know
um I I went to the hospital though and
I'm okay
so far anyway
uh but
to get out of that situation
um
at first there was about six people
holding me captive
and they took me
to maybe it was a swinger club I don't
know where I was I really don't know
but eventually it was just one guy
holding me captive and I was able to
convince him that I wanted to be there
um even though this is really
embarrassing they wouldn't let me use
the bathroom and they would they're
making me wear an adult diaper uh
uh which is disgusting
um
and uh
you know they're threatening me with a
blow torch they're gonna burn my head
so they're they put the flame right by
my face and uh
uh you know it was scary it was pretty
scary
um welcome to L.A yeah yeah right um and
like I'm thinking no I'm I'm from the
west side of Chicago you know I could I
could handle this I never in a million
years thought that I would be a rape
victim ever
ever
um
I kickboxed for eight [ __ ] years you
know I can handle myself
and I was held hostage and raped it
happened yeah you're drugged
um yeah yeah if the drugs is really what
did it I guess it's some stuff called
liquid G it's what somebody was telling
me
um but uh I I convinced this guy
basically
that uh I I want to be his boyfriend
and I got him to let his guard down
enough for that I could Escape out of
there
when I did Escape out of there I was in
the grenshaw part of town Crenshaw
grenshaw
um
and didn't know I had no idea you know
even what side of town I was on
um but I was so weak from my diabetes
and not getting my medicine I literally
was crawling on the ground
um and I would have to stop and take
breaks and wait on the sidewalk
and no one seemed to ask if I need help
or anything like that which is kind of
alarming I I try to help people when I'm
walking around if I see like they're in
trouble not not the white guy not the
white guy on the sidewalk though uh
and uh I I got away
um
and um
I'm still kind of in shock about it
um I'm ashamed about it I know it's not
my fault
I just feel like I wish I could I was
smart smarter than to fall for that
um
and I'm angry about it too
and the thing is I don't know who it was
I don't know really where I was because
the place that I got out of that was in
Crenshaw or grenshaw was a cranner grand
see I got a Crenshaw
uh it was like an apartment complex
wherever they took me
it was like
some strange little mini town is the
best way I can describe it like there's
a house here a barn here everyone had
neon stuff on it almost looked like a
rave that's why I thought maybe it was a
swinger club or something like that
but uh I I had no idea where that was
um so even if I wanted to retaliate I
wouldn't know who to retaliate on
and it's just something that I have to
live with now life in the streets yeah
yeah you can you can blame your drug
addiction yeah and that's what it is
it's it's really it all stems from the
drug addiction
um
I've uh
a lot of loss um have you been in love
before yeah it's interesting you asked
me that because that's kind of where I
was going next and uh
so
uh I used to have a son
um
if I start crying I'm sorry this one's
hard to talk about a little bit even
harder but uh
I I call her the ex-pirate hooker
um this woman because there's a couple
women in my life but the ex-pirate
hooker is the type of lady that doesn't
love her own kids she's a sociopath
doesn't have the ability maybe
psychopath honestly it doesn't feel
emotions
and we had a son
um when he was three months old
I found him in the crib with a sudden
infant death syndrome
which is uh
they can die a few different ways from
it but I found him like that
and um
well don't be sorry yet
um this this was the most terrifying
experience of my whole life was holding
my baby in my arms and he was gone
um I brought him into the living room
everyone in the house there this is that
ex-pirate hooker's family's house by the
way but I brought him into the living
room everyone was crying and
I'm agnostic
so I don't even really like to say the
word God I don't know what it is
something took over my body at that
point
I pushed everyone out of the way I
remember thinking he's got little lungs
don't breathe too hard
um so I'd puff a couple Aaron as long as
and I used two fingers to tap on his
chest after the third time I did it he
woke back up again
uh when the paramedics got there
you know did somebody breathe Aaron him
I said yeah I I did they're like you
saved his life good job
um which was I had dreams about finding
dead babies for months after that it was
horrifying
well that's when he was three months old
two months later
uh I come to find out he's not mine
biologically
um and that uh uh was it broke my heart
to say the least
but um
the pirate hooker said oh the real dad's
gone you know there's no way he's ever
going to be around
and that was my son you know I caught
his umbilical cord he had my middle name
my last name and especially after what
happened when I found him
um I was very attached to him I nursed
him with the bottle she couldn't even
make breast milk
that was my baby and uh nobody was gonna
tell me otherwise
um and I raised him for five years
and um
well in the fifth year
turns out biological dead wasn't gone he
was there the whole time I just didn't
know it
she knew it and Court battle ensued
long story short because that I can make
that one long but I'll shorten that
segment up
um I had full custody of him
and uh I ended up signing my rights off
because at the last court date
I was so dope sick
that I couldn't even uh get dressed I
was fetal position
and I had my lawyer sign my rights off
on him
which I believe was the best thing to do
at the time
because he's now with his biological
father
they have a house
they have jobs he has brothers and
sisters now stable uh environment that
he can grow up in maybe I was putting
his wife just to save him that one day I
don't know
um I miss him every day though you know
um
sorry about that
a lot of twists and turns
so
um
you know I wonder if he even remembers
who I am
but uh
so I meet this other amazing woman later
and it's interesting too because her her
now ex-husband
was a sadistic piece of [ __ ] who raped
and beat her for seven years
[Music]
um
he is now ex-husband
and I was with her through the whole
Court thing with that but I have a
daughter with her now too
and um because again of my [ __ ]
addiction
um when she was pregnant I relapsed and
uh
she ended up
having giving birth
uh I didn't know when she was born so
I'm not on the birth certificate
she put her into an open adoption
um
but the good news is
the first night she tried to leave her
with the adopted parents the baby hunger
struck would not eat food she wanted
mom's boob
so Mom ended up moving in with the
adopted parents and they haven't been
away from each other not one day
um
and
uh so that's that's good
and I'm still very much in love with uh
with her
but
um she doesn't drink or use drugs she
comes from a very very hard background
but her inner child
uh
has an attachment to me because her
parents are drug addicts
and she's been waiting for me to get my
[ __ ] together for about five years now
and I'm losing her I'm trying not to I
would really like to work things out at
this point I just want a nice boring Mr
Rogers life
uh would be my dream come true and just
be a dad
but it's a lot of work that I I gotta do
but
there's there's hope there where I can
hopefully not lose a second child and be
in her life that'd be nice
um but uh
I have what's called borderline
personality disorder
um so
when I feel things I feel very deeply
I when I love I love hard
and when I'm depressed it's actually
called psychotic depression
um so people that have what I have we
have the highest percentage of suicide
I tried to commit suicide several times
um
just because the the lifestyle is hard
um you know constantly having to survive
every day
I'll tell you this though since I've
been to La the weather's lovely I never
want to see another snowflake ever again
um that's why I'm here yeah uh
and it's it's nice in that aspect but uh
as far as that goes
if it doesn't work out with her
I give up on love after that because I'm
only 40 but I do have whoever cancer now
uh it's stage four
I'm not going to get radiation I'm not
going to do any of that
um because it doesn't really make much
sense for me to go get chemo and then go
away on the sidewalk uh
you know like a concentration camp
victim weakness laying on the sidewalk
homeless I'm not going to do it my
theory is my I you wouldn't guess if I'm
looking at me but uh my body I got
pretty good genetics and I feel like
it's learned to adapt to it a little bit
so when I go I go
but um
the the drug addiction now at this point
is uh I feel like it's keeping me alive
um
when I was held prisoner uh
uh last week
um I thought I almost died because the
pain was so unbearable
and my blood sugar was so low
uh this past year I have fallen into a
coma twice because of it which is a
really weird feeling going into a coma
um so I mean I'm 40 years old but I feel
like a senior citizen
um I I've experienced flashbacks from
the PTSD where I'll actually think I'm
in a different year
uh
uh like 15 years ago it's in I'm living
then
and
um it's a scary feeling when you can
kind of feel yourself losing your mind
that that's what scares me more than
anything I don't want to lose my mind
um I hope I'm dead before that happens
um
but uh every single friend that I've
ever had is dead mainly from overdosing
or getting shot
um when the heroin epidemic
in about year 2000s when it started
everybody's gone now
um and I'm alone and
that's how I go through life I I keep to
myself
and I really scraped by the skin of my
teeth every day you know it's I'm
surviving every day
it stems from the addiction it does and
um
nothing nothing that's good in life
comes easy
and
I've learned the hard way on that one
there's a difference between being
stupid and foolish I'm not stupid but
I've made some very foolish choices
and
um if you can be wise enough to not make
those choices
more power to you
um but uh
I wouldn't want anyone
to have to experience the life that I
have
we'll see if I make it to 41.
I hope I do the best of luck with that
and uh peace and love to everyone that's
watching this
all right Nate thank you very much no
problem